all right we are
live on the youtube i'm dave rubin and
we've got another friday panel bonanza
for you
today we'll be discussing the importance
of living a healthy lifestyle in a time
of covid
and joining me today are host of the
genius life podcast and author of genius
foods max lugavir
fitness trainer and health coach gina
florio and professor of
medicine at stanford university and a
research associate at the national
bureau
of economic research dr j barachayara
welcome to the reuben report everybody
nice to be here thank you thanks for
having me
all right doc i'm going to start with
you because we're hearing a lot suddenly
in the last couple weeks
that body mass index and obesity have a
lot to do
with mortality rates related to covid
and i heard you on megan kelly's podcast
a couple weeks ago and you were talking
a bit about this can you
can you kind of fill us in on how
important body mass is related to
staying healthy right now
sure i mean it's it's it's important for
staying healthy just generally just
apart from covid for covid
it's it's i mean the single biggest risk
factor is still age so every
six or seven years of age you're double
double your risk of death
conditional and getting covered um so
age is the most important thing
just to give you some sense of how poor
body mass index is if you go from
from normal weight to overweight uh
that's like adding maybe
uh a year up to your so like i'm 52 that
would be not the same risk as a 53 year
old if i were overweight
and then if going from overweight to
obese that adds about
let's say five years uh so i'd go from
like 52 to 57 year old risk
um and if you if you go to morbidly over
east
obese that's like 10 years of risk
something like that so it matters it
certainly matters
i mean but as we said that it matters
for so many other things too so it's not
just covid
yeah max since uh i've had you on a
couple times talking about health and
you kind of helped me straighten out a
little bit of
a little bit of my eating habits and the
rest of it um i'm guessing this doesn't
surprise you that that some of this is
connected to body mass and weight
no i mean obesity uh and overweight in
this country are huge problems i mean
the the latest statistics suggest that
two-thirds of people are either
overweight or obese
and you know the bmi is a is a is a
it's a uh uh a metric that look people
love to hate on right because it
it basically we arrive at it uh via a
simple calculation using your height and
weight
um and so there's been at least from my
vantage point on social media this push
back to all of this really
what i think is very empowering evidence
to show us that by achieving a healthier
body composition we might
become more resilient you know against
pathogenic threat
but a lot of people like to argue that
the bmi is an imperfect
unit of measurement and that's true that
is true because it doesn't incorporate
it doesn't really paint the full picture
of your health but
no single marker no single number that a
doctor can measure on any lab
does it doesn't account for lean body
mass so if you love to go to the gym
it's not going to be able to tell you
that you have more or less lean body
mass but the truth is that
when you zoom out at the population
level the bmi is actually very useful
um because most people are not outliers
right most people are of average body
composition and
average in this country now
unfortunately uh is overweight and obese
right people love those outlier cases i
remember you know 20 years ago when
shaquille o'neal was
you know a huge nba star huge no pun
intended but he
i think according to his bmi he was like
morbidly obese and yet here he was
obviously in prime shape running up and
down the court so of course there there
are those outliers
uh gina you're a fitness instructor
what can people be doing right now
because i've noticed a lot of people it
seems to me that a lot of people
basically either got better got
healthier in the last year
or just sort of went off the deep end
the other way there's very little in
between
yeah that's true it definitely is one
extreme or the other i mean it's
it's no surprise that we've ended up
here i mean i think it was even in the
1950s the national institutes of health
declared that obesity was a national
pandemic in a way and it was a metabolic
disorder of the age they said
and so now we've arrived at this very
unique place where
i also think that our culture has
prepared us to
accept obesity as the norm now and i
think that's something that we
definitely need to talk about because if
you see what's happening in
digital media publications on the cover
of magazines we're now
being told that obesity is not only
beautiful
but we're actually being told that
obesity is healthy there was a cover of
cosmopolitan where a morbidly obese yoga
teacher was doing a yoga pose and the
headline
was literally this is healthy with an
exclamation point
so i think what we're also seeing is a
very interesting
moment in american culture where we have
been taught that
it's somehow offensive to even talk
about obesity rates and talk about
uh the effects of obesity so it's you
know especially as people in the health
industry
it's almost a lose-lose for us because
nobody wants to hear the statistics
because people have been conditioned to
believe that
it's rude to even bring them up yeah so
i'm really glad you brought that up uh
dr j i'm
guessing that you probably struggle with
the degree of that that people are so
leery
of everything right now depending on
where you get your news and what podcast
you listen to
and if you obviously if you watch cnn
you're getting very different
information than
than fox and we're all doing that that
it's becoming hard to trust numbers on
top of what gina's talking about with
just this culture war where suddenly
things that things that we all knew to
be true 10 years ago now
are just up for debate i mean i think uh
there's there's that i i i really i
really regret that it's a political
issue
i mean i didn't realize it could become
a political issue coven's become one
which is just
mind-boggling to me um and obesity
certainly also
shouldn't be a political issue it is
absolutely the case that if you are
overweight or obese you you are at
higher risk for a whole number of
chronic diseases
um and conditions it's it's healthier to
be to to
address that i mean so i mean that's
just a medical fact
i mean i guess maybe if i try to think
about a a
a reason for this we don't want to
stigmatize disease we don't want to
stigmatize people who have a disease or
condition
you want to you want to provide them
with with resources at uh you know
i mean you know to to address those
those kinds of conditions without
shaming i mean i think that maybe that's
what the culture is trying to address
but you should be able to do it while
still
squarely looking at the fact that you
know if you're if you gain
too much weight you put yourself at
higher risk for for bad medical outcomes
so max give us give us some of the foods
i ask you some version of this every
time i have you on the show but for
somebody that's watching this right now
that
maybe put on a couple pounds during this
or is not feeling great
about their weight but maybe they don't
want to bust all into a new fitness
routine or whatever
what are some of like the little things
that they can do start adjusting to
to be healthier yeah i mean i think the
biggest problem with the standard
american diet which is what most of us
are hooked on like an iv
drip is that it is is just you know
saturated
in what are called ultra processed foods
foods that are uh
generally um their protein content is
diluted so they're minimally satiating
they're dehydrated
and they provide no dietary fiber so
those are all those three ingredients
right there are what make a food
satiating and unfortunately today 60 of
the calories that we're consuming
come from the inverse of that foods that
are highly calorie dense and minimally
satiating so
the advice that i give people i mean we
can get into the nitty gritty about low
carb low fat
you know you know whether or not
plant-based is the right diet or a more
animal centric approach which i believe
is the the more appropriate and
biologically sound approach
but ultimately anybody will benefit from
minimizing the consumption of ultra
processed foods and shopping around the
perimeter of their supermarket which is
where they
they'll tend to find the fresh
perishable foods you know foods that
have
single ingredients those are the foods
that are more likely to fill you up
there was a study performed i believe it
was 2018
at the national institutes of health by
a well-known obesity researcher named
kevin hall
who found that when people eat
predominantly ultra processed foods
which is what americans are eating
they naturally will eat themselves to a
calorie surplus of about 500 calories a
day
if you do that every single day over the
course of a week that is a pound of
weight gain which can easily push you
into the territory of being overweight
or obese
so i think if any if people were to make
one single change
it's to look at the food quality you
know look at the foods that you're
eating and make sure that they are of
that
minimally processed nature so in the
midst of all this gina they also closed
the gyms and i'm here in la where my gym
is still closed right now even though
newsome our governor is telling us that
on april 1st april fool's day of course
we're going to start opening up some
stadiums or something but the gyms are
still closed that
must drive you nuts it does because it
it hinders people from being able to
live a lifestyle that's going to help
them
move forward and take care of their
health because you know there's
there are many things that we can do
when it comes to daily lifestyle
and diet and exercise but i mean the
biggest thing for me is just the fact
that people are stuck inside their homes
and that people are encouraged to not go
outside and see the light of day
i mean i think one of the biggest issues
that most americans face is that they
spend
on average like six percent of their
life outside we're stuck inside all day
from nine to five we're under the
fluorescent lights we never see the sun
i mean the sun is
our biggest source of energy it boosts
serotonin it boosts testosterone levels
it improves our mood and there's so many
things that being out in the sun does
for us
and all of a sudden we're told to stay
inside and when you go outside cover
half of your face
and we need the sun to regulate our
sleep wake cycle and
this the quality of sleep that you get
also really affects your health and your
weight so
it's just it's frustrating that i see
all these people
self-isolating and staying at home and
not getting outside and of course
we're gonna be more unhappy we're going
to gain more weight and we're going to
choose to eat all these ultra processed
foods because
we're in a bad state mentally and
emotionally right so basically
they lock us in our homes and then they
tell you you can't go to restaurants
okay you can't go to the gym so now
you're ordering in more food we know
you're going to order yes
chinese or pizza basically and then
you're not going to work any of it off
um for covet i mean you need vitamin d
vitamin d
deficiency is a major risk factor for
for poor outcomes for colvin i mean so i
just it's very very counterproductive
these lockdowns they're not really well
thought through
um even for covet itself yeah
let's go let's go a little further with
that actually so do you think there was
any science
behind the lockdowns like even when when
they started basically a year ago now
was there any reason to believe that
they could possibly work
i mean i think they're just inhuman
right you they you basically they think
they if you
if you have a uh rats and you put them
in cages apart from each other they
won't infect each other
that that is essentially the the
sophistication i think of this i mean
the models themselves uh have them have
these like
you know little sims where they they you
you just
you make people not interact and uh yeah
the disease doesn't spread
uh but the problem is everything else
about human life right so we have to be
in
in interactions with other we have to we
have to be like being in isolation
is psychologically incredibly damaging
um and we can't do it we just cannot do
it
without suffering severe severe
consequences um
in the early days we even knew in the
early days who was really at risk it's
the old older population
you know we and certain certain people
with certain chronic diseases um
we should have done everything we could
to protect them
while still trying to maintain normal
life instead we panicked everybody
and what what's happened is uh young
people you know you all
um you have a higher risk you you think
of the covet as a more risky thing that
actually is for you
and so you don't go out i'm not you all
i mean obviously but like a lot of a lot
of young people i've seen
um whereas older people they they in
some sense they underestimate their risk
and they take more risk than they should
instead instead of like this good
accurate public health understanding of
who's really at risk if we've given
people that tool
they could have managed it their lives
around that around that risk more
appropriately instead we panicked
everybody
and we get this unfocused these these
unfocused lockdowns that have caused
absolutely devastating harm
yeah yeah i've been i've likened it in
the past to
uh abstinence education versus safe sex
education
i've seen other people uh do the same
thing you know
from the get-go it should have been harm
reduction
you know arming people with the
information that they needed to make
informed choices
letting people know that if you have
comorbidities you know the average
there was that study that was published
over the summer that found that the
average person to die with covet 19
had 2.6 comorbidities 2.6 other
conditions on average
um you know this the the data
surrounding age
and obesity and all these you know other
other figures should have been laid out
there for the public so that they could
then make their own choices you know
people who are older
stay home you know quarantine do what
you must
uh but yeah that to me uh jay was
exactly i think um the difference
between safe sex
education and abstinence education the
latter we know
doesn't work you know when you when you
tell people to just stay
uh abstinent what do they do they rebel
and you know
obviously problems ensue do you guys
think gene i'll start with you do you
guys think that this has fundamentally
changed the way people
trust or don't trust the experts the
scientists our government officials
i'm meeting a lot of people especially
here in los angeles max you're here too
where it's like people that were not
political at all before this thing began
are are becoming very political because
they realize
that you have to in an odd sense you
have to be political if they won't let
you go to work
yeah i actually noticed that too in my
own circles i find so many more people
who are suddenly interested in politics
and who are suddenly interested in
getting involved because
i think what we've been seeing is an
incredible frustration and distrust
of of experts right so first dr fauci
said
there's no need to wear a mask you don't
need to wear a mask and people fiddle
with it doesn't really work
you know he said that and the next thing
you know he's saying everyone must wear
a mask and the next thing you know he's
saying people need to wear two masks and
we're sort of sitting here asking okay
hold on a second so if it if the safest
thing
is to wear two masks why didn't you tell
us that from the very beginning
you know why are you withholding that
seemingly important information and so
you now you have a lot of people who
maybe aren't on either political aisle
but they're suddenly getting frustrated
because
what these lockdowns have done is ruined
many people's lives in a very real way
shut down businesses um it's hard to put
food on the table for your children
and people have you know lost their
livelihood and there are real tangible
consequences so people are suddenly
getting involved
they're getting upset because i think
they're starting to realize and wake up
to the fact that these experts experts
they're getting paid a ton of money
to say whatever is most convenient and
so it's mobilized a lot of people i
think to get involved which
you know it could be a blessing and a
curse but at the same time but i think
that it's
at the end of the day it's actually
really nice to see people sort of wake
up and get involved
yeah what do you think about that doc
just that i think there's just like an
exhaustion at this point
this is sort of what we were talking
about before but like there's just like
this exhaustion of listening to experts
because then people look at the tweets
from a year ago and it's like wait a
minute you were telling me to go outside
you were telling me
not to wear masks you were telling me
all these things now you're saying the
reverse and then people just start
tuning out all together now we've earned
the distrust of the public we absolutely
have earned it um and it's it's it's
really
it's just really too bad um because you
know the the uh
i think that public health and science
can play a very very positive
role in giving people tools that inform
good information and it's just we just
haven't done a very good job of that
this year
this past year gina highlighted some of
the contradictions
i mean i remember the cdc director in
the summer said that mass are more
effective
than vaccines i couldn't believe it the
cdc director said that
um i i mean i think uh i think
the the the lockdowns i think the a lot
of the experts that have made these
kinds of comments
um they they're they're thinking
strategically how can i get you to do
what i want you to do
right how can i enforce these lockdowns
because they're trying to act against
this
exhaustion that comes from these inhuman
orders
um and so they're they're just i mean
and so they end up
latching on to things that don't make
any sense to anybody they're not
actually scientific
and i just i think it's a catastrophic
mistake it's going to take a long time
for public health to regain the trust
if it's ever possible um that someone's
had
max you've been a little more outwardly
political you're not like
i don't consider you really a political
person in a strict sense but you've been
a little more outwardly political on
this and it's like
you know when i go to florida i'm in
florida and people are living their
lives
and i was at restaurants and they were
literally you know florida's an old
state
in terms of age there were 90 year old
women having drinks at bars living their
lives
making the choices for themselves um and
then yet we're here still in los
angeles under this situation um you're
gonna help me with this recall of new
sim or what that's where i was going
with this
yeah i actually i did fill out the uh
the recall form because i just think
that
you know the draconian orders put in
place were arbitrary from
the start i mean i could understand
again going back to the sort of safe sex
harm reduction analogy
you know i'm a conscientious being right
so if i'm around somebody who
who is who has the potential to be
at high risk if i'm in a indoors in a
public place
um i'm gonna do what i think is logical
and reasonable for
for me to do right but like the notion
that gyms
uh gyms have been closed for months
right which gyms i think should be an
essential
essential service i mean they're a way
to you know
encourage metabolic health you know
something that only 12
of the united states population can
claim ownership of
uh but meanwhile i've been able to shop
in malls this entire time yeah so to me
there's this
there's this disconnect there's a
dissonance that to me
um feels political it doesn't feel like
it's grounded in science
um and so the fact that politics have
sort of
somehow been able to seep in and
intervene and play a role here and you
see the statistics about people
you know on surveys rates of anxiety
depression or just shooting through the
roof people are comfort eating
you know leisure time physical activity
is at an all-time low
uh it's just really disheartening and
counterproductive to
what we should all be rallying behind
which is keeping people safe
but these efforts actually see these
mandates seem to be counter to that
and to me it's very frustrating so
you're right i've been sort of stepping
my foot forward a little bit
um and uh and yeah i just hope things
change soon it seems like they are
yeah thankfully yeah jesus what about
that that mental component to the
to the physical workouts like everyone
knows when you work out it's not just
that your body feels better
mentally you feel clearer happier all
that stuff
yeah there are just endless benefits to
exercising regularly i mean down to how
you sleep down to bone density down to
sex drive
um down to um you know boosting
serotonin and just feeling so much more
clear-headed
down to self-confidence and um it's it's
an immensely important
part it's a fundamental part of health
and you know even more than just
exercise going to the gym and lifting
weights is something that we call
non-fitness movement just getting 10 000
steps a day
just going out for a walk oh for a walk
first thing in the morning for 30
minutes um you know
move around maybe even like cooking is
non-fitness movement right
doing these things that just encourage a
kind of lifestyle and habits that are
going to last you
in the long run and with this the
self-isolation
there's just no way to do that you know
there's there's no way to actually
engage in these things you can't even
even going to take a dance class all
these things that that contribute to
holistic health and a really strong
mental capacity
we're missing that and it's no wonder
it's no wonder we're seeing rates of
anxiety and depression
spike um you know on top of people just
not getting outside never seeing the sun
being totally isolated not seeing their
friends
not being able to do the things they
love and even down to starting new
hobbies you know those things are so
good for our brain and for
our mental health it keeps us engaged it
keeps us excited and
and it helps us move our life forward
and it's just it's really sad to see
people
literally sit in their home and
deteriorate yeah yeah
especially in a state here like
california i mean i'm uh you know just
to throw my own personal n of one
anecdote into the mix i'm a highly
motivated person
you know i'm really interested in
fitness and exercise and i found it very
difficult to
you know to get those ten thousand steps
in as gina was talking about
non-exercise physical activity which we
know is so important to our health
and there's such a low barrier to entry
as well but just the fact that you can't
seemingly do anything
and especially here in california and on
the west side where i live
people will actually give you weird
looks if you're not wearing a mask outs
when you're walking outside by yourself
which to me is just completely insane
now we've we created this culture of
shaming right that that you're you're
you're if you've had coverage or
something wrong with you you weren't
careful if you don't if you were not
wearing a mask you don't care about
other people
instead of creating a culture of of of
your affirmation like trying to trying
to give people tools
good good good uh public health advice
it's it's really crazy
um i think the uh i think the the um
the psychological damage really can't be
overstated like that
like one in four young adults this past
june in a cdc survey
seriously considered suicide in the
united states one in four that should
have ended the lockdown right there
i mean just think what we've been doing
doing to our young people it's just it
it's mind-boggling of course the
isolation affects young and old alike
but um
actually you know the other thing about
the lockdowns it's sort of
under-appreciated
is is how um i mean i think of it as
trickle-down epidemiology
it's protected people who can afford to
have jobs
that have have zoom it but it hasn't
protected
uh poorer people you know working-class
people in
la county uh like
places like santa monica or or beverly
hills
uh have one third the number of covert
deaths per capita
then poorer parts of ellie you know
compton
um you know watts one third i mean it's
it is really one of these things where
uh
it's it's protected the rich at the
expense of the poor
and i mean ironically i think in the
ways you all are saying
harm the bridge with these the sort of
the psychological
isolation it's it's um just a
catastrophic policy for health
doc where are you at with um excuse me
where are you at with vaccines
now because you know joe biden last
night basically was saying you know that
everyone will have at least the
opportunity to be vaccinated by may
first again that's a
a year plus three months past two weeks
to flatten the curve
and then he said if basically everyone
behaves
that by july 4th you can have small
gatherings
in your backyard but it's like people
are already doing it and the more that
they keep pushing this it seems to me
they're just going to keep saying things
and just more and more people are just
going to ignore it but where
where are you generally speaking with i
mean that i
i think the vaccines are actually quite
a good thing i mean i think use and
we've done a
pretty good job first it's it's amazing
to me that they were they were developed
in such a short time i mean
you asked me at the beginning of the
epidemic would it be possible
in fact i was asked i don't think it was
possible i didn't think it was possible
i mean that's a huge scientific advance
and that's i mean that's
that should be celebrated and we've also
most states anyways have used them
correctly
to protect the vulnerable to vaccinate
older populations my mom lives in la she
finally got the second vaccine a few
days ago
and it was huge relief to me because you
know they really is quite effective
against severe so i think and so i think
the vaccines once we
have protected the old with them the
vulnerable
what is the reason to to worry so much
about cases like let's
the all the collateral damage is so
catastrophic
we should stop the collateral damage and
resume our normal life immediately why
wait till july
uh we're gonna i think by the end of
this month we'll have everyone over 65
in the united states
will be all have been offered a vaccine
at that point what's the
what is the reasoning to stay locked
down yeah do you guys all
think that everyone should be vaccinated
i mean it seems to me that the push now
is not just we're going to vaccinate the
older people and the other people at
risk
but now it's going to sort of be if you
aren't vaccinated and if you don't have
a card or something to prove you're
vaccinated
either we're not going to let you on a
plane or i mean you can really go down a
rabbit hole with this stuff
but max what do you think should
everybody be vaccinated even the
the 40 year old healthy person that's
taking care of themself
and just literally yeah i i think a lot
of my followers would probably expect me
to be just
you know blatantly anti-vaxxed but i'm
not i'm
actually totally in support of the
vaccine for people who are at risk
you know my somebody in my family who's
at risk is gonna is gonna get the
vaccine and i'm fully in support of that
i think people who are at risk should
should take it um am i personally
uh gonna be you know rushing to to get
it i don't
think so because i don't you know i know
my health pretty well and i know that
i'm not
at risk uh even though i do potent
potentially run the risk of
being exposed to the virus i think
that's just something that we're that's
here to stay um but i uh
but i i have to agree with jay i think
it's a very it's just an
incredible feat of human ingenuity that
we have it you know it's i believe it's
the first mrna vaccine
that uh has been put to market which is
incredibly you know
beautiful science and um and so yeah i
would
you know recommend that anybody who is
at risk uh
uh get it for sure for me with the
vaccine yeah i think the biggest thing
for me is that
it's being used as a threat and that's
what i really don't like is that we're
now
we're now being told by by leaders and
politicians that if you don't all get
this vaccine we're never going to be
able to open again we're never going to
get back to normal
well that's that's not what the vaccine
should be used for is to threaten people
and
and and say that we all absolutely must
take it i mean i'm in the same boat as
max i personally know that i don't need
the vaccine
but i'm if if you feel like you need it
if it's your choice to go get it more
power to you i'm not going to stop you
i'm not going to say i'm not you know
the anti-vaxx person either but
the whole point is that we should all
have the choice and we should all have
the choice if we want to take it
and if we don't want to take it that's
fine too so the biggest problem for me
is that it's being used as a threat and
that's what really upsets me and i think
that's where we see the biggest problem
is that
you know biden saying that if you all
behave like good little children i'll
let you go have a july 4th
uh barbecue i'm like well nobody that's
not the way that it works
not in america no not if we follow your
orders and if we behave in the way that
you want us to
then we're allowed to go live our lives
the way that you you are allowing us to
so i think that's the biggest thing for
me is that it's being used as a threat
i completely agree with speaking my
language go ahead doc i mean i mean i
think that's really
again it's a public health mistake right
can tell people
for whom the vaccine is a really good
idea that it's a good idea
in a trustworthy way present them the
evidence and then let them make good
choices around that that's how what good
public health does
if this this this i mean just i'll give
you one thing what uh we
i think something on the order of half
the country has already been infected
with with covet
right so if you if you just account for
asymptomatic infections and
just i mean i've done some calculations
about say roughly half the country
uh why do we have to have everyone
vaccinated if half the country's already
been infected with covet
uh i mean it just doesn't make any sense
and actually it's very again it's one of
these things where
it privileges the the rich uh
it's real the relatively well-off that
are more
enthusiastic about the vaccine uh
vaccine hesitancy is much higher among
the poor
and we're going to create a segregate
segregated class of people
that oh you're not vaccinated so you
can't go into a theater i mean that
doesn't make it
when in fact they're probably already
immune because they've they had some
asymptomatic infection
um you know i saw i thought from i just
it just doesn't make any sense it's bad
public health policy instead we should
be using the vaccine to protect the
vulnerable
and for people who are who are scared
about covid again the vaccine is a
fantastic idea there are classes of
people on for whom the vaccine hasn't
been tested like children it hasn't been
tested and frankly i'm not going to let
my children have it until
until it's been tested frankly even then
i might not want because
covid might be better for my kids than
the vaccine um
for for me it's i'm going to i'm
probably going to get i'm older than you
all so i you know
i i'm at a higher risk than you all um
uh
you know yeah health care workers you
know frontline workers i think
you should be able to make that choice
and you know and and do a
cost a risk benefit analysis you know
like
individually um but also you know
where is the messaging uh from our
officials that
you know pounding home that like we need
to get in we need to get in better shape
as a nation
uh i mean that messaging is nowhere to
be found um it's just you know
m.i.a and i think that's really sad also
because vaccines traditionally
work less they're less effective in
people who you know have co-morbidities
who are overweight
who have you know chronic low-grade
inflammation things like that
so uh that to me is is you know i'm
still disappointed where
are you know where is that messaging
yeah and we're now being told that it's
a conspiracy theory to believe that the
immune system can do what it's built to
do
and that's where it gets me it's like
we're not talking about ways that we can
equip ourselves in daily life and then
if we dare
to speak about it if we dare to talk
about um ways to boost our immune system
we're called the conspiracy theorists
yeah so i got one more for you uh
because
everyone knows i try to end all of the
shows with with something hopeful and
actually there's been quite a bit of
hopefulness here
and we know that these lockdowns are
ending even if it's taking a little too
long but i'm curious for all three of
you
is there anything in the past year that
you're that you're thinking
fundamentally shifted on because i'm
finding that a lot of people
are thinking about things in a new way
and thinking oh maybe the government
can't do everything for me can't fully
keep me safe all of these things which i
think is
is a net good thing even though it still
feels a little scary right now i'm
curious if you guys
had any fundamental shift max i'll start
with you we'll go the other way
yeah i mean to me it just drives home
that you know
personal accountability isn't something
to be underappreciated and that we
each need to take steps in our own lives
uh to
to procure better health for ourselves
and to educate those around us you know
to be sort of the beacons
in our own communities whether that's in
our families to our friends on social
media
to lead the way the best way to teach is
to lead by example and so
that's personally what i try to do and i
think the tools are out there
you know compared to prior generations
we you know we're we're more invested in
our health we're more
invested in our you know personal
development we you know
science is fairly ubiquitous you know
everybody has access to
scientific publications for the most
part or at least abstracts or at least
you know journalistic interpretations of
that science and i think um
you know there's no time like the
present than to
seize the reins of your health and to
you know whether it's small steps or big
steps to you know to really like engage
with it because once it goes
you know it's something that's you know
your health is
like chronic an ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure
um is what i think and so uh you know to
just close with the
john f kennedy quote that i really love
you know the time to fix the roof is
when the sun is shining
um and i think that if there's anything
that that the past year has shown us
it's that
yeah doc anything that you shifted on in
this past year
unfortunately it's not a hopeful thing i
i i did not realize how fragile the
consensus around
free speech and free expression was even
within science and
scientific discussion and within public
health uh i mean i think one thing
that's come
very very clear to me is that it is
actually quite fragile indeed the people
that speak out against
a consensus even that when the science
is loudly
pointing in one direction are liable to
get pounded down
um there's a lot of danger around that
in the future of science scientific
discussion frankly in the future a free
free society
um and uh yeah i think that's something
that that's not going to end with the
lockdown unfortunately
all right gina now you got to bring us
the hopeful ending because
that wasn't that wasn't it was
appreciated but not the hopeful part
yeah i don't know if mine's hopefuls
i'll be perfectly honest i mean the
biggest thing for me is just i
am so much more aware of government
interference than i've
ever been aware before i mean i am
almost at a point now where
i'm asking why on earth are there seat
belt laws why does the government
get to decide and get to find me if i'm
wearing a seatbelt
in the car that i paid for using the
insurance that i'm paying for why are
you making me wear the seatbelt means
the same thing with the mask
what does this have anything to do with
the government so i don't that's
definitely not hopeful but i'm at a
point where it has
honestly gotten me to the point where
i'm so hyper aware of government
interference and the government
overreaching and telling us how to live
our lives and telling us to do this and
that
for a reason that i honestly can't wrap
my head around
and that's where i'm at too i mean i
don't that's definitely not hopeful but
it's made me so much more aware
you know it kind of is hopeful though
you woke up to liberty in the midst of
all of this and i think a lot of people
did so
i i think that's a perfect uh place to
stop i'm gonna continue without you guys
for a minute or two but dr j
maxx gina i thank you guys we're gonna
link to all your stuff down below
and uh stay safe and i hope to see you
guys in actual real human life one of
these days
thanks dave um by the way guys i should
mention
that uh max over there just joined
locals and it's maxlugavir.locals.com so
if you want some advice on eating and
brain health and all sorts of good stuff
maxlugaber.locals.com
you know guys i did a periscope before
we started this thing a little live
video streaming
on twitter which by the way we are
adding that functionality to the locals
app it
is coming soon we already have live text
chat in there but we're adding live
video streaming
but anyway i did a periscope a little
bit before where i had to i had to
apologize
uh to the people of the world because
you know joe biden last night was saying
you know this thing about may 1st
if everybody's vaccinated and you behave
and keep listening to us even though we
keep moving the goal post
that maybe at that point you can have a
couple people in your backyard to
celebrate independence day
which independence day is all about
being free from these tyrannical leaders
but maybe we can do it
in four months from now which is about
16 months after two weeks to flatten the
curve
and that whole thing but anyway i was
watching that and then uh
well we had a dinner party at our house
last night
we had eight people over for dinner we
had chicken
and salmon and bok choy and faro and we
served
small ice cream sandwiches at the end
and uh
everyone that came over could be dead
right now i have no idea i haven't heard
from anybody today
and uh look the point guys is that
go ahead and live your life you don't
need me to tell you
and you don't you actually don't need
experts in a way to tell you that like
make whatever choices you think are
right for you and your family
that's the only way society is going to
get fixed like if it's not obvious to
you at this point
that the top down way of looking at
pretty much everything not just the
pandemic but government in general
and all of the institutions and
everything like that's why
i'm enthused right now you know like i
was little i was a little
dour earlier in the week about things
because you just hear about their coming
for pepe le pew
and they're taking out dr seuss and mr
pretended and this movement of
destruction it's here
it's here and it's going to keep coming
there's no doubt about that but what we
talked about there at the end that
people are
waking up to what liberty means like
and what freedom means and the best
thing the only thing you can do
in a way in the midst of all of this is
just figure out what works for you
and the people that you love and the
people that you're around in your local
community
and i think people are starting to do
that so i am i am enthused
in that way and that's uh the feeling
that i'm going to take into the weekend
i've got a couple more meetings today
i do have any live hits today i was
supposed to be on ingram tonight but
they they gave us the boot do we have
anything else today i think i'm on i
think i'm on something a little bit
later i'm on something a little later
they're giving me the
oh i'll be on uh joining seb gork on
newsmax
a little bit later today he's guest
hosting perhaps angling for a full prime
time slot on the newsmax so i'll be
joining serb gorka which is a name right
out of star wars so that's why i'm doing
the show
and i like that guy he's all right
anyway guys have a good weekend
enjoy your friends enjoy your family
take a walk
do some exercise read a book listen to
some music you don't have to wait for
the government to tell you it's okay
it's gonna be okay dave told you all
right thanks everybody
see ya